Founder Office: Hello, good nun… kudaser.
Suresh: Me too.
Founder Office: akar pekir.
Founder Office: Hilda?
Founder Office: example aki.
Suresh: Elder.
Suresh: gett dem Broader die Zeitung.
Founder Office: Hilda Gibt.
Founder Office: They embroidery dietote.
Founder Office: meaniniking.
Founder Office: Jurgen Sygan die Freunde, die photos. Jurgen kianama person kinek.
Founder Office: deriva.
Suresh: Jogan?
Founder Office: metanan.
Founder Office: Psyched. Psyched.
Founder Office: kan nunel.
Suresh: Mmm.
Founder Office: Ryan, then?
Founder Office: The photos.
Founder Office: Jurgen Seit, den Freunden, die Photos.
Founder Office: no one.
Founder Office: Hi, Luke.
Founder Office: air cleared.
Founder Office: dem Bruder, demater.
Founder Office: Ich etzel di familia de creme.
Founder Office: seleh.
Founder Office: Ich er selder.
Suresh: death.
Founder Office: Er familia.
Founder Office: Dan Krimi.
Founder Office: Ich ertzele der Familie den Krimi.
Founder Office: Yeah, next, die gross motor shenken.
Founder Office: Die ankle kinder eine tarfer shopolade. Di gross motorhinkan kian tagi karina, kapi wah biker ponchuliit karano na singular subject.
Founder Office: De Grosse Motel?
Founder Office: grandchildren, ya.
Suresh: I mean…
Founder Office: karno.
Founder Office: Die Grossmotel Shinkt, eta kudemaitanapi di ankar kinder kinakat toura karan nadaat.
Founder Office: Then… karnum.
Founder Office: cholada.
Founder Office: ain gust, ain coffee.
Suresh: Yeah, go ahead.
Founder Office: object, sorry, verb beka. Viya kohan kaat is connected. Viya kohan Ainam Gust.
Founder Office: Wir Kohan Ainam West.
Founder Office: akir.
Founder Office: ini.
Founder Office: para nih.
Founder Office: kara mega.
Founder Office: Peter Bildenzie said, sir.
Founder Office: ka naaman.
Founder Office: Ich Kaufen dem Hund.
Founder Office: I, in a nutshell.
Founder Office: Ich Kauver dermund einen not ein Nortchell.
Founder Office: ya.
Founder Office: Baladin, an auction.
Founder Office: ya?
Founder Office: der Nortshell nikkel.
Founder Office: karada.
Founder Office: I don't remember.
Founder Office: kashva.
Founder Office: ako satif.
Founder Office: Shreiban kiene kit theemai, shrapen kiene kita aptuk dharmaman, kart de la ni mukakdata. Karta de kiene ketif, mokaid akosaatif.
Founder Office: kaatadeh.
Founder Office: kukati.
Founder Office: ka.
Founder Office: Object Zeka kawasher nama.
Founder Office: nahi.
Suresh: Miram, marim.
Founder Office: in attendance.
Suresh: homework, open kalina.
Founder Office: prostatif Object.
Founder Office: plus naatif Object.
Founder Office: Tom Git.
Founder Office: Der Lerin. Tom gibt der Leyrarin ein B.
Founder Office: Tom Dinema Teichertapadak.
Founder Office: Tom gibt der Leyarin ein boh.
Founder Office: ain pok.
Founder Office: Tom Gibt, der Lehrein, ein Borg.
Founder Office: Die Frau hat heute geboard.
Founder Office: Yeah?
Founder Office: Via?
Founder Office: Hadani.
Suresh: Oh, dear…
Founder Office: Liam Schenkan.
Founder Office: Kapi, frau.
Founder Office: Die Frau hat wait ja burst.
Suresh: Yeah.
Founder Office: Wir Schenken der Frau Blumen.
Founder Office: na.
Founder Office: D. Kinda.
Suresh: Beautiful.
Founder Office: in Git?
Founder Office: Demute gibt dem Kint einen kus.
Suresh: I'm getting it.
Founder Office: the moon.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: Kibt dem Kind einen. Puss.
Founder Office: hai.
Founder Office: Di liarin, verb bekapita di lati no, gay ben. Shenkan keen diaphit di la tiene. Di lair in tapi… web biker.
Founder Office: kibe.
Founder Office: Di laharen gibt inangatan student.
Founder Office: Student ten kyanne plural, no, api hat.
Suresh: Which…
Founder Office: house of gobal.
Founder Office: khara.
Founder Office: Chairman Saint.
Suresh: It's not okay.
Founder Office: Sinkht… Ber Frau Kantameter.
Founder Office: der Frau, einen die Mountain Ring.
Founder Office: Thai ke.
Founder Office: Di Frau with karan wah bingo.
Founder Office: Helen.
Founder Office: Die Frauschengt.
Founder Office: Yeah, man.
Founder Office: team, and… Die Frau Shinkt demon ain kravate, kantaate aktak karna. Die Frau Shinkt demon ain kravate.
Founder Office: Janet.
Founder Office: It was about ane?
Founder Office: Die Kindle, die Grosnutte, die Briele.
Founder Office: Miss dinner.
Suresh: Well, before you get…
Founder Office: gross material.
Suresh: The gross.
Founder Office: I gross material.
Founder Office: They are grossmotel.
Founder Office: making them even their gross motor.
Founder Office: Be brilliant.
Suresh: P.
Founder Office: die kinder geben der Gros Mutter die Brileen.
Founder Office: word teka.
Suresh: Yes.
Founder Office: naman.
Founder Office: A langre? Karnaman.
Suresh: Yes.
Founder Office: Tengst. Whist.
Founder Office: Freundin, be Freundin, girlfriend.
Suresh: Yeah?
Suresh: Yeah, fine.
Founder Office: Yeah, they are frying bean.
Founder Office: der Freunding som Valentine's stock.
Founder Office: der Freundin su Valentine Stark.
Founder Office: Do find some Valentine star.
Suresh: It was strength. Thanks.
Founder Office: Have a argument online.
Founder Office: Ron?
Suresh: -
Founder Office: Yeah. Sync.
Suresh: Valentine.
Founder Office: Dame Freund. Was Schengz do, dem Freund so Valentine Stack.
Founder Office: Was James Lew Dame Freinsung, Valentine Star.
Founder Office: Ich Hond Kse.
Founder Office: en.
Founder Office: Asian people.
Founder Office: Ichtenge.
Founder Office: Behrund Imbahtiv Dembehen.
Suresh: him.
Founder Office: cookies deno han.
Founder Office: Shokoladan.
Founder Office: Mia Schenka.
Suresh: Interesting.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Suresh: The skin.
Founder Office: Kindle.
Suresh: Yeah.
Founder Office: And that Yeah, then Kinden. Via Schenken, then Kinden, Chocoladin. Apilamente, chocolate Tagu Karina.
Founder Office: begin Krashnei.
Founder Office: Como na pigame.
Founder Office: Shane?
Suresh: Right.
Founder Office: indi ni kar.
Suresh: D again.
Founder Office: Kinden.
Suresh: green on Monday.
Founder Office: of polarized.
Suresh: London.
Founder Office: forage ka.
Founder Office: Schengt ihr den Kinden auch chocolate.
Founder Office: question, question, it passa verbekta. Ilangar de subject.
Founder Office: Ilambertion, ma'am?
Founder Office: Yeah.
Founder Office: Air gifts. Air gift card dinne.
Suresh: Damn fart.
Founder Office: Dem farte.
Founder Office: Yeah, good.
Suresh: they… Patrick, this idea.
Founder Office: newspaper, okay, the meaning.i.
Suresh: I in it.
Founder Office: INSATO, okay?
Founder Office: nin.
Founder Office: Okay, fantastic.
Suresh: It's too.
Founder Office: Yeah, he was due.
Founder Office: Gibbs do later in the house.
Suresh: Everybody.
Founder Office: number.
Suresh: Anyhow, it's Robin.
Founder Office: face seedi.
Suresh: Dune.
Founder Office: Gifts do, they are layering, the house of God. Gifts do, de-layer in.
Founder Office: Die Haus of Gabe.
Suresh: B.
Founder Office: layer it in?
Suresh: Gibt.
Founder Office: Yeah, they layered in Git.
Founder Office: Who's style name Hinan?
Founder Office: I didn't name it.
Suresh: There we go.
Founder Office: Course tile name ke lapikinun course. Yeah? Di layering gift methodan bahu chana, it per mukhaktap y articlean ha.
Suresh: then…
Founder Office: Dane. That if Cloran is a Dane.
Founder Office: Die Lehrein gibt den K questain nemen einen.st.
Suresh: Thank you.
Founder Office: participants letter to stick up.
Suresh: Ich Schenke.
Founder Office: Yeah, Ishenke.
Suresh: Hmm… Dear Martin.
Founder Office: Yeah, Ishenka, they mentioned…
Suresh: Sorry, mention. Yeah, merchant.
Suresh: How do you find it.
Suresh: It would take a 10 minute.
Founder Office: Kinda.
Founder Office: Happy mukaktaki, Nikka.
Founder Office: aka na Namak mitral dasfara.
Suresh: Oh, my goodness.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Suresh: Ma'am.
Founder Office: cinema.
Founder Office: Farad.
Founder Office: aka.
Founder Office: Webs Dala.
Founder Office: tender.
Founder Office: perih.
Founder Office: Monamage.
Suresh: Mmm… I'm gonna go.
Founder Office: Whoa.
Suresh: kiloga.
Founder Office: second ti aanne.
Founder Office: api saha.
Suresh: Oh, my God.
Founder Office: tiaani.
Founder Office: Okay. Yeah.
Suresh: homework done, may open college.
Founder Office: karladana.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Alright, man.
Founder Office: im maquusatif.
Founder Office: sehannet, very, very nice.
Founder Office: h, ya.
Founder Office: mehtanan.
Founder Office: jetikar.
Founder Office: Nailed.
Founder Office: adeh.
Founder Office: kaid.
Suresh: -
Suresh: Rhino sine agility.
Founder Office: eta kudapiara.
Suresh: traffic.
Founder Office: Shinkt karate,
Founder Office: Sainer frau.
Founder Office: einen Blumenstrauss.
Founder Office: Okay, malika, karin naman.
Founder Office: sorry shitty.
Suresh: I'm leaving that.
Founder Office: So nice to meet you.
Suresh: Pardon me, Sunayon.
Founder Office: kapiya.
Suresh: Yeah, dying sign kinetic at the bottom line? Dying sign…
Founder Office: Oh, mind sign keine ka.
Suresh: Find guides.
Founder Office: Oh, ma'amang komina, contain. Just explain karal na, mintanak.
Founder Office: Sorry, ke.
Suresh: What is the main animatum keywords?
Founder Office: Bonita, huh, huh.
Founder Office: Okay. Than das.
Founder Office: article defini saha.
Suresh: Let me take 10 minutes.
Founder Office: a screening share will end up here.
Suresh: Pretty much everything.
Founder Office: Innovative.
Founder Office: article deka binne.
Founder Office: Bienander.
Founder Office: Yes.
Founder Office: article deka.
Founder Office: nikka.
Founder Office: Method D.
Founder Office: personal pronouns kiene ka.
Founder Office: madel.
Suresh: IQ?
Founder Office: no.
Founder Office: kanwa.
Suresh: Female legat na minor.
Founder Office: Plural. Yeah?
Suresh: Understood.
Founder Office: kapai.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: plural naam.
Founder Office: Plural ngapi parachikar ana.
Suresh: Mine.
Suresh: Feminine na, mind hit water.
Founder Office: surge.
Suresh: Alright. Femining ng.
Founder Office: mehaktan.
Suresh: Do…
Founder Office: Kurtin?
Suresh: Like…
Founder Office: meani.
Founder Office: Dain. Daine. Dain, dain.
Founder Office: kar harane.
Founder Office: Mukade. Sign. Sign.
Suresh: I ain'.
Founder Office: meinh.
Suresh: Yeah, you cannot.
Founder Office: Yeah?
Founder Office: Yeah,
Chathura Praboda: Yeah.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Oil.
Founder Office: Met tenant.
Suresh: Beautiful.
Founder Office: of a quinoa.
Suresh: Absolutely.
Founder Office: Yeah, honestly.
Suresh: Yeah? Who said it.
Founder Office: Unseere. Unse, unsere.
Founder Office: berane.
Chathura Praboda: Neither of it.
Founder Office: ane.
Suresh: Oh.
Founder Office: Sorry, deka moya lagi, oya ll me nettan, oya re.
Founder Office: karan ni, Yere only.
Founder Office: Yeah. Yeah? Yeah.
Founder Office: karame.
Founder Office: Eco quido.
Suresh: Take a look at.
Suresh: E-U-E-Royerade.
Founder Office: Kokader, Suresh.
Suresh: kilogada?
Founder Office: tenant.
Suresh: Yeah, man.
Founder Office: Yeah, Oyel, oyre.
Founder Office: Oya, oyre, quiera tama ya pigment. Oya, oyre.
Founder Office: theta.
Founder Office: His wife. Blumen Strauss.
Founder Office: seiner Frau einen Blumenstrauss. Ehindi tape mein processifada, adalindi nikan karna mein mage tanaka di.
Founder Office: Er, air, air clad.
Founder Office: Sign zone, sign a doctor. Okay.
Suresh: put that as Doctor.
Founder Office: Be house self-government.
Founder Office: kieneke.
Suresh: Deerson in…
Founder Office: i negar.
Suresh: Signer, yeah.
Suresh: How do we take it.
Founder Office: Suresh.
Suresh: How do you have it.
Founder Office: karane mehtanagi.
Founder Office: Air eclat, cyanim zone.
Founder Office: kada.
Suresh: Detox.
Chathura Praboda: BW.
Founder Office: A doctor.
Suresh: Did you guys secure the iron?
Suresh: I did.
Founder Office: Okay?
Suresh: M.
Founder Office: Di house of garban. Homework.
Founder Office: Make a broken clear, then.
Suresh: Oh, okay.
Founder Office: Go ahead and…
Suresh: karne hai.
Founder Office: hitter.
Founder Office: namkelah.
Founder Office: Net tangapigaani main, minor keela.
Suresh: Oh, mine, mine.
Founder Office: thru rarna.
Suresh: Alright.
Founder Office: Okay, Deca, yeah?
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: okay.
Suresh: Yeah.
Founder Office: Way naktan kinapi Christmas.
Founder Office: ahu.
Founder Office: kara nakira.
Suresh: I thought, DKinder, you know, another DK.
Founder Office: get.
Founder Office: Assign, assign?
Chathura Praboda: ER.
Founder Office: kaput danone.
Founder Office: kini.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Suresh: in Canada.
Founder Office: signal hinder.
Founder Office: Pakita.
Founder Office: Dunn. Kocht air.
Suresh: the family.
Founder Office: nahi.
Founder Office: article, de ka.
Suresh: Del Family Manager.
Founder Office: Di Familia. Di familia sein ti an diagram ka vin ne ha.
Suresh: Did you get DM?
Founder Office: Fairly.
Founder Office: Yeah, they are better. Done, cocked air. Dear Familiar.
Founder Office: Essence on the camera, yeah?
Founder Office: a kamak.
Founder Office: Dun cocktail der Famil ein Tolles Eschen.
Founder Office: Hey, Langate, daya unt.
Suresh: Doing at home.
Founder Office: Kenne?
Suresh: Through the deal. Damn.
Founder Office: und ehr gibt dem Hunt.
Founder Office: Okay? Ain nurture.
Suresh: Not sure.
Founder Office: na das.
Suresh: I… that's funny.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Founder Office: no ne hai.
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: Ain Nurture.
Founder Office: Ilangatabalan, off.
Founder Office: Light… Light, air, einfrein, sine autof.
Suresh: daya divini.
Founder Office: Devin ne.
Suresh: That's naming it.
Founder Office: Oh, last name, ape datin eka, datamayaindi la ti ni sama in denominator Suresh.
Suresh: No.
Founder Office: ak denama.
Founder Office: kartaine.
Founder Office: I agree.
Founder Office: que lateno, sign out okay lateno.
Founder Office: ka.
Suresh: It doesn't work there.
Founder Office: luata keela.
Suresh: I ain't know.
Founder Office: I'm never frightened.
Founder Office: I never joined Mukakdad in it.
Suresh: Does auto. You can sign out again.
Founder Office: sign autof.
Founder Office: Okay, no meansabala na.
Founder Office: A tenure?
Founder Office: Air?
Founder Office: Kilt of feminine.
Founder Office: Fremdel.
Founder Office: Gen Zemet thing ho keen denimunader.
Founder Office: The touristen. Tourist slat.
Suresh: Goodbye.
Founder Office: Okay, ma'am, think to register now.
Suresh: Touriston.
Founder Office: 2 are Eastern. Ehu ka?
Suresh: Hit the correct den.
Founder Office: nikka.
Founder Office: keratin.
Founder Office: meada.
Suresh: -Oh.
Suresh: Yeah, they were the.
Founder Office: Amy Kimmy, good.
Suresh: I ain't wait till then,
Founder Office: den vek jaila, yeah?
Founder Office: aka.
Suresh: Oh, maybe?
Founder Office: Metronominar diferentiene.
Suresh: We're not doing Linden.
Founder Office: evening.
Suresh: Howdy, I get it.
Founder Office: a little print.
Founder Office: karate.
Founder Office: A longer term?
Founder Office: meek, no ha.
Founder Office: no.
Founder Office: Okay, ito patihtana mukaktaitiani. Velan keela keena pe sirekaran keela keena, ain verb web bikak.
Founder Office: dawase.
Founder Office: We're calling…
Suresh: Environment.
Founder Office: naham.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: management hatha.
Suresh: I thought we can either.
Founder Office: Switch.
Founder Office: I mean?
Founder Office: aiendo.
Suresh: Cinnamon major paper.
Founder Office: Hermane de personal pronounen en dad.
Suresh: Alright, right.
Founder Office: niada.
Suresh: -Oh.
Founder Office: Yeah, methane diaphikerangana de itivk second ko humidapi personal pronoun ka, bhavita karate. Etu put nominative keysne personal pronounsama, ka.
Founder Office: Okay? ne.
Suresh: D.A.
Founder Office: denamaha.
Founder Office: der lere gibt matter. Okay?
Suresh: -Oh, okay.
Founder Office: mata.
Founder Office: Do you hear that?
Suresh: nahish.
Founder Office: kila.
Suresh: Alright.
Founder Office: Indirect object matakee aneur mein pawsi karate, ya? Heta ko aaphi karate mishke any kane mein mi aki na pada, mata keen. Okay?
Suresh: Dude.
Founder Office: Mia, sorry, dia.
Founder Office: kiene.
Suresh: Ian.
Founder Office: seem clear.
Founder Office: Ilanger.
Founder Office: kafte.
Suresh: E.
Founder Office: karan mein.
Founder Office: madh.
Suresh: Here.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Founder Office: akhani.
Suresh: Uns.
Founder Office: Uns.
Founder Office: E oya la, oya latte.
Suresh: Oish.
Founder Office: Boys.
Founder Office: Okay? Own, own te…
Suresh: Wound, he in it.
Founder Office: api kian.
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: karate.
Founder Office: Yeah, did you do that.
Suresh: Okay. Teng aapita indirect eka indirect ng.
Founder Office: Oh.
Suresh: personal pronoun,
Founder Office: Sorry?
Founder Office: They're open.
Founder Office: Synced.
Founder Office: Me and…
Founder Office: Be opent me ein B.
Founder Office: genike.
Suresh: -Oh.
Founder Office: na
Founder Office: Suresh.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: Very good. Api k seandunaga ape se ka tan wo ta mein mishda di meadi tiya no Suresh.
Founder Office: Go ahead, delete that.
Suresh: How clear.
Founder Office: Okay. Yeah, it passive.
Founder Office: Papa… Out. Do. Owns.
Founder Office: I'm ice.
Founder Office: kaouda.
Suresh: Up it again.
Founder Office: ain ice.
Founder Office: deno.
Founder Office: 9.
Suresh: Ich Kaufen. Euch heute ein ice.
Founder Office: Haute, kain ice.
Founder Office: dar.
Suresh: Kaustum ya einen.
Suresh: Luft Balloon.
Founder Office: aku satif the.
Founder Office: 9 tom.
Suresh: Luftwal.
Founder Office: pointe auch.
Founder Office: akina.
Founder Office: auft.
Suresh: Enin.
Suresh: Kaina?
Founder Office: Right.
Founder Office: This is chitin. So you say chitin Jenny Sweets.
Founder Office: Der farte Kauft eenen kian meinne unt, etter.
Founder Office: sweet saran denit nehe.
Founder Office: un.
Founder Office: namel.
Suresh: Show.
Founder Office: officers.
Founder Office: Pulluwang.
Suresh: Global artists without Karnegan?
Founder Office: Suresh.
Founder Office: ka.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: Woodstock.
Founder Office: Alex hat hauteboard stack.
Suresh: shrinkling?
Founder Office: Thank you, huh?
Suresh: I ain't.
Founder Office: Im, im ein farad.
Founder Office: Ischenka im Farad, okay? Ichenka im, ain Farad.
Founder Office: Alexa Choiter geboard star Alex Yadu Pandane, is Shenkarim ahouter.
Suresh: Yeah, yeah.
Founder Office: Personal pronouns, Pavicharane.
Suresh: I didn't…
Founder Office: Oh.
Suresh: In farad kilometer.
Suresh: I'm sorry, that didn't.
Founder Office: Etana Tapital.
Suresh: In farad kilometer? E-I-N. Sorry, IHN. IHN. In farad kilodamat?
Founder Office: One of the remaining…
Suresh: Huh?
Founder Office: So, I would take you up with an email.
Founder Office: Oh.
Suresh: kara.
Founder Office: do a gatee.
Suresh: the na.
Founder Office: Oh, I… product, I cannot give aake is Schenke.
Suresh: in Farah.
Suresh: I didn't go.
Founder Office: Etarang gan na beha ha muka dapin mehavastawe di Aniwari mein, karta te desi kinaput gela yan deity second tian donesh.
Founder Office: Suresh.
Founder Office: no ini.
Founder Office: ape se ka identify kanai kanu tamae, tamay, yapi itanezi, na mennei.
Suresh: Alright.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Founder Office: Et a passer, die looken aus.
Founder Office: Wir Schreiban deem kint ainakata. Apilian karteka, yeah? Wir Schreiban deem Kint ayna karte.
Suresh: Email.
Founder Office: We are Schreiben im a hotel. Wir Schreibern im ainakata.
Suresh: I mean, fuck.
Founder Office: kil.
Suresh: There…
Chathura Praboda: Junk longer.
Suresh: Bring, yeah, layer…
Chathura Praboda: And they have no bloomer.
Founder Office: Blue woman, okay?
Founder Office: Der Jung bringt, der Larry Blumen.
Founder Office: bringt. Ruminut.
Suresh: Yep.
Chathura Praboda: year.
Founder Office: Yeah, okay, der Junge bring to bloomer. Okay?
Founder Office: kaufo.
Founder Office: IM Fighter D.org.
Chathura Praboda: Yeah, look.
Founder Office: digah.
Founder Office: mukhattan.
Founder Office: mein watchaka.
Founder Office: Lumedrai, die Elton Geben Dem zone einen Fussbah.
Founder Office: Parents of dinawa laminate puthate football. Di Elton Geben Dem zone, einen Fusbar.
Suresh: Im Dan.
Founder Office: kir mein.
Founder Office: Yeah, it per se, der Kaufman. Kaufman can be businessman. Der Kaufman?
Founder Office: size.
Suresh: Fine.
Suresh: Damn.
Founder Office: Same month.
Suresh: over.
Founder Office: Desitone. Der Kaufmann seit, yeah?
Founder Office: decide on Patrell, yeah?
Suresh: Oh,
Founder Office: Okay? Okay.
Founder Office: gibt Melanie einen Ring.
Founder Office: Max gibt Melanie einen Ring.
Suresh: Melody gift you.
Founder Office: Melanie Gibt Max ain kus.
Founder Office: Melanie gib, ohute kinata mini kissa, melani gib im ain kus.
Founder Office: Melanie gift im ainen kus.
Founder Office: Di shuler.
Founder Office: Bem Lara, bem dust po.
Founder Office: That's true.
Suresh: about a negative.
Founder Office: Fo.
Founder Office: mukakhda.
Suresh: Like a male teacher connect in the evening.
Founder Office: keine ka.
Founder Office: akh.
Founder Office: Die Arbeiter Bauern, den Kindle einen spielplayer.
Founder Office: ainan.
Suresh: Still plot.
Founder Office: Okay?
Suresh: heeland.
Suresh: DR.
Suresh: LinkedIn.
Founder Office: kar de ka.
Chathura Praboda: Oh, damn.
Suresh: They're masculine,
Founder Office: masculine, say I got. Masculine buade kya pe objete ki aini hammerame masculine. Ay in meini animari mein method na ampa there.
Founder Office: Nate, dea doctor.
Suresh: I know.
Founder Office: nitkar na.
Founder Office: Di mute.
Suresh: Niche.
Chathura Praboda: Yeah.
Founder Office: keela, yin.
Suresh: drop.
Founder Office: Yeah, ain' intro.
Founder Office: niece.
Founder Office: nichte.
Suresh: anymore.
Founder Office: Their uncle cowft, their neister.
Founder Office: der nichte ein Ice.
Suresh: Oh, good.
Founder Office: the mein.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: Okay, yeah, good. Eho kunar de mere podi exercise ke kaakte hainema, auf gabat sway ke. Second exercise, CD pass onar pronounman, api kanangatan dia miya eine keh.
Suresh: What do you fucked.
Founder Office: Yeah, okay, it's Corey Grenin Susamal. Masis no minds.
Founder Office: Their father cowed.
Chathura Praboda: Dear father.
Founder Office: hint.
Chathura Praboda: And kinch so a lot.
Founder Office: Hmm?
Founder Office: Dem kin chocolatel. Er kauft.
Founder Office: Air Kaufed.
Suresh: Im.
Founder Office: aim.
Suresh: Oh, hotel.
Founder Office: aircraft in.
Founder Office: Auch ein nice. naise.
Chathura Praboda: Yeah, candy.
Suresh: Can I innovate.
Founder Office: Hmm?
Suresh: Happy to advertise.
Suresh: Bob, how is…
Founder Office: kilne breed.
Suresh: So, that brings them on.
Suresh: INNT.
Chathura Praboda: item D.
Founder Office: Ainante, okay? Deya kerne bringante.
Founder Office: Er bringt.
Suresh: They are linked.
Chathura Praboda: Im auf einen.
Suresh: structural.
Founder Office: Er bring, yeah, good. Im.
Founder Office: lag.
Founder Office: Kr.
Founder Office: No mandra, e.
Suresh: 1KG.
Suresh: kan skeh.
Founder Office: special keika.
Founder Office: kann.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Doctor.
Suresh: Beautiful.
Founder Office: And it is?
Founder Office: Ich berstelle.
Founder Office: Dear?
Suresh: Yeah.
Founder Office: Mama, order karin na?
Founder Office: Dear, oya.
Suresh: Time or two.
Founder Office: Mark done.
Suresh: she…
Founder Office: On pizza.
Founder Office: Ich Bestelle?
Founder Office: How?
Founder Office: Ryan, slash then, Paula.
Founder Office: Et tenemocada.
Suresh: relationship.
Suresh: Unsenone. Unsene.
Founder Office: mata.
Founder Office: U-M-Lis.
Founder Office: Which bestseller owns?
Founder Office: Owl.
Founder Office: Stripe, flashing, cola.
Suresh: I shouldn't grow up.
Founder Office: Yeah, soy, fresh, and kola.
Founder Office: Coca-cola bottles dekakut a biter keen. Ich beester oils uns, sorry, Ich best teller uns auch zweil flashen kola.
Founder Office: a tenant.
Suresh: Their mind shrinked.
Suresh: Signer. Freundin Blumen.
Founder Office: Yeah. Damon?
Suresh: Yeah.
Suresh: Shanked, shanked.
Founder Office: Cynard Freundling, okay, girlfriend, okay? They are man-site.
Founder Office: Signer, destroying them.
Suresh: Blue woman.
Founder Office: Blumen.
Founder Office: Elanged. Er. Shinkt.
Suresh: Airstream.
Suresh: Here, euch einen Ring.
Founder Office: Huh.
Founder Office: Yeah, and synced.
Founder Office: aka.
Suresh: Yeah.
Founder Office: Yay.
Founder Office: auch einen.
Founder Office: auch einen drink.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: Bear.
Suresh: Yeah, the other.
Founder Office: Git.
Suresh: GIP… Student turn.
Suresh: How's golfing?
Founder Office: to daily channels.
Suresh: Go.
Founder Office: Yeah, there they are the Gibt Den Studentil, House of Gabana den Studentil kinapidanne.
Founder Office: Plural, and the native plural is to dental. Okay, good.
Founder Office: Then stood in turn.
Suresh: Air GIFT?
Founder Office: Ina.
Suresh: Enoch.
Founder Office: tenide, and I mean…
Suresh: Is there an example?
Founder Office: Simple. Oh, simple ke… simple.
Founder Office: test. Okay?
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: kegan ako.
Suresh: Oh, I mean…
Founder Office: It's near the minimum agrica.
Founder Office: Minimity.
Suresh: -Oh, yeah.
Suresh: Edison.
Founder Office: beka.
Suresh: Helfan.
Founder Office: kiene.
Suresh: Dougar, no.
Founder Office: tiene.
Founder Office: Taha anitaeka.
Founder Office: objet.
Founder Office: Landen, yem?
Suresh: Oh.
Founder Office: likta.
Suresh: Pitiganda puluang…
Founder Office: they'.
Suresh: Habigamo.
Suresh: No.
Suresh: Nope.
Founder Office: Yeah, code again.
Suresh: Okay, yeah.
Suresh: And now they have drew the situation.
Founder Office: They are brooder. I said, what? Okay, they are brooder.
Founder Office: brooder ke ne subject.
Founder Office: kilft kedagarny.
Founder Office: i.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: Yeah, switch it, yeah.
Suresh: Shit.
Founder Office: sekatha.
Founder Office: Did you do that.
Suresh: Oh, stop.
Suresh: I don't know, I don't know.
Chathura Praboda: Can I, opposite to Native?
Founder Office: Makatu?
Founder Office: sayin.
Founder Office: kan keyword.
Founder Office: nahi.
Founder Office: keysaki.
Founder Office: Meh, Derida.
Founder Office: Oh,
Suresh: I'm looking at her.
Founder Office: Okay? Yeah. Uma te keera.
Suresh: ish.
Suresh: Ish, yes, huh?
Suresh: Ich Helfer.
Chathura Praboda: You should…
Suresh: Yeah, oh man.
Founder Office: Team Oma.
Chathura Praboda: bail.
Suresh: Ich Alfred dem OPA.
Founder Office: aapi… Dative keysne verbs.
Founder Office: to thank. Thank kar, no.
Suresh: Don't.
Founder Office: kya.
Suresh: Mmm…
Suresh: Donut.
Suresh: the… their doctor down there.
Founder Office: Yeah, the doctor. Dunked.
Suresh: Demfarta.
Founder Office: So good.
Founder Office: Be doctor.
Founder Office: Don't.
Founder Office: Di doctor, damp fat, okay?
Founder Office: ant waten kiana.
Suresh: Reply, turn around.
Founder Office: Yeah, no, replied.
Founder Office: ka… There, student, capital DN. Student… Ant?
Suresh: unwater.
Founder Office: watered.
Founder Office: Dair student unto it, der professed mein moan.
Suresh: Damn provision.
Founder Office: The M Professor. Professor, okay?
Founder Office: Their student, and voted them professor.
Founder Office: Student Antwater name, professor, student professor Ant Sakarna. Okay? Pirate na.
Founder Office: Their student voted deem Professor.
Founder Office: kera, okay?
Founder Office: sapatu.
Suresh: Interesting.
Suresh: Do you show a person.
Suresh: Take a pro roll? Is she working on, right?
Founder Office: Oh, Suresh?
Suresh: Excluded.
Founder Office: appointment.
Suresh: Do you show a person?
Suresh: Demkind.
Founder Office: Yeah, be sure.
Founder Office: name hint.
Suresh: damn kid.
Founder Office: Pasel.
Founder Office: Ilanging balana.
Suresh: Huron. Gihurin. Gehorin.
Founder Office: belong, okay?
Founder Office: Das Haus, geharen die Frau.
Suresh: And that's house.
Suresh: Gihud?
Founder Office: That's house… Gibbert.
Founder Office: Gehurt, der Frau.
Founder Office: Das Haus Gehurt der Frau.
Founder Office: Ilan natinama, der film Gefahlen. Gefahlen kian gleicher.
Suresh: They are field goal in Bulani?
Founder Office: Oh, Bayer Film, Mempadagna brand, Bayer Film.
Suresh: The film.
Founder Office: to get coronavirus.
Suresh: Give her.
Founder Office: Bear Film.
Founder Office: Give it.
Suresh: Defeated.
Founder Office: nahpi.
Founder Office: Der Film, der Feld Mir.
Suresh: Mia…
Founder Office: Okay? na.
Suresh: Oh, yeah, they felt. De… Damn auto.
Founder Office: nominative.
Founder Office: Okay, na tan.
Chathura Praboda: Kauto Geffold meal?
Founder Office: Oops.
Chathura Praboda: Thus, auto-g effort.
Founder Office: put dake kara.
Chathura Praboda: a.
Chathura Praboda: That's true.
Founder Office: Oh, now, meke ne varks. Then sudish kewagya peyah gifaan di puluanga dori temaro karla. Na muktape te mama kaikat kameti kyati mama kian.ceh ka.
Chathura Praboda: validate.
Founder Office: Mukanderout?
Founder Office: Definitely.
Founder Office: Yeah, ishma annehari.
Chathura Praboda: mein.
Founder Office: Honey Marine, yes, yes, yes.
Chathura Praboda: Exactly.
Founder Office: Filmmaker.
Chathura Praboda: Oh…
Chathura Praboda: They are probably…
Suresh: Their… their film?
Chathura Praboda: Their partner.
Suresh: Yeah.
Founder Office: Rapid,
Chathura Praboda: AFN, get 5?
Founder Office: wah.
Suresh: Team Farter.
Founder Office: i, ya?
Suresh: Dust booth effect.
Founder Office: Give it.
Chathura Praboda: have built.
Suresh: Der Muten.
Founder Office: Das woke gefert der Mutter Mutter.
Founder Office: batakarani.
Founder Office: Per nada.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: kiya.
Suresh: Hmm, that's mine.
Suresh: That's a dear man.
Suresh: Lim.
Founder Office: Alright.
Suresh: Dear man, ge felt.
Founder Office: Gift hit.
Suresh: Hmm… I forgot one.
Suresh: Lembus.
Founder Office: kenne de.
Suresh: Whoa.
Suresh: -Oh.
Founder Office: ter nada.
Founder Office: Okay. Busge Demand.
Founder Office: Avidhattuk, yeah?
Founder Office: Okay. Yeah, the pizza shmekt air. Yeah?
Suresh: The pizza Schmidt?
Founder Office: Pizza, which mixed.
Suresh: E.
Founder Office: Im, yeah?
Founder Office: Le Pizza Schmicht die.
Founder Office: Di pizza shmektim.
Founder Office: mat krase.
Founder Office: Como de quierre.
Suresh: Dude, you so schmacked me.
Founder Office: acai ki namana.
Founder Office: Okay, so pegarasay, pay a tip.
Suresh: Even in Mia.
Founder Office: Yeah, okay.
Suresh: I mean?
Founder Office: Di zupe.
Suresh: Schmidt? Schmidt.
Suresh: Eat.
Founder Office: 8, 18.
Founder Office: tiarene.
Suresh: You know what I mean?
Founder Office: Oh.
Founder Office: dapi kian.
Suresh: Ish, gradually at…
Founder Office: Huh?
Suresh: I know finding?
Suresh: Hmm. Dan Freundling.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: Female water.i.
Founder Office: It's gradually erased.
Founder Office: aaph salmane.
Founder Office: gratulia re… Ainel freundin.
Founder Office: Okay? Ish grassholy hare.
Founder Office: What is your pronoun, Anika Demon?
Suresh: Hmm… Michigan…
Founder Office: What would that be done.
Founder Office: Is graculiere, magi na miner.
Suresh: Whatever.
Founder Office: Minus.
Suresh: Mine enough.
Suresh: Yeah.
Founder Office: minor findy.
Founder Office: makta.
Founder Office: Maya Scholler?
Founder Office: Pretty And there is so… Web.
Founder Office: Ber shriele.
Founder Office: share.
Suresh: Good.
Founder Office: Hit.
Founder Office: Hmm?
Founder Office: D. Schooner?
Suresh: Dem layer. Yeah.
Founder Office: Yeah, good.
Founder Office: der, der Schulele Hertz. DEM.
Suresh: And
Founder Office: Cool.
Suresh: noda.
Suresh: In the audio.
Founder Office: ini.
Founder Office: Suresh, okay? Mama Hano, Mukat dahan directo objetek hai ka ako sati fahanadi. Okay?
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: ine.
Suresh: Halfen.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Duncan.
Founder Office: Duncan, thank you nika.
Suresh: unwritten.
Suresh: Passen.
Founder Office: Fasan. Fasan.
Founder Office: Yelang are good.
Suresh: Literally.
Founder Office: belong, kiene ka.
Founder Office: belong. Yeah?
Founder Office: hi.
Founder Office: It could end in a hand.
Suresh: Oh, you're not.
Founder Office: mukhaktih.
Suresh: Give Father.
Founder Office: Gefa lende.
Suresh: Schmeck… Schmeck.
Founder Office: You know what time?
Founder Office: Graculier.
Suresh: Miram.
Founder Office: Yeah, graduate, ya.
Suresh: Suhan.
Founder Office: kineikinek.
Founder Office: aka.
Founder Office: What kind of question am I today?
Suresh: VIM.
Founder Office: seh rumih.
Founder Office: ka.
Suresh: Auto.
Founder Office: The Sauto, Dominican.
Founder Office: The brille. Specs, yeah, glasses. Die Brile.
Suresh: Nope.
Suresh: How was it? That's house.
Founder Office: That's house, yeah, that's house, okay? Yeah, itu ketapita dano nam Prashnya, kaheti ka tada.
Founder Office: Vein't adhes, okay?
Founder Office: karna.
Founder Office: hertz.
Founder Office: outo.
Founder Office: tiarene.
Founder Office: Okay? Question verdhiker. Yeah?
Founder Office: karate.
Suresh: Go home and dad.
Suresh: Das Auto East.
Founder Office: Yeah, that's sauto.
Chathura Praboda: Right.
Suresh: -
Chathura Praboda: And then some people…
Founder Office: Auto.
Founder Office: So, that's how… sariman Gehparallel, inautho…
Suresh: That's how would you get her own.
Suresh: Out of Gehart.
Founder Office: kait machet.
Founder Office: Basauto gehurt meiner.
Suresh: That's how to get hooked.
Suresh: DFR.
Founder Office: That's auto gear.
Founder Office: That's auto gahertz.
Suresh: They're farted.
Founder Office: tiya.
Suresh: I'm a damn fun.
Founder Office: Suresh, yeah?
Founder Office: samhai.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: We gehalenjiene.
Founder Office: ganama.
Suresh: VIN?
Suresh: That'd be cool.
Founder Office: like.
Founder Office: Ven. Gfeit.
Founder Office: das Buch.
Founder Office: How would they put the cavity, yeah?
Founder Office: kyanne.
Suresh: Vem de faire.
Suresh: I am.
Suresh: Oh, nice, sorry.
Suresh: Geoffreel.
Chathura Praboda: thus moved?
Founder Office: Dasbu.
Suresh: That's.
Chathura Praboda: You feel it?
Suresh: Woke me up.
Founder Office: Gefert Mia.
Chathura Praboda: I'm mute.
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: miya.
Founder Office: dihaya.
Founder Office: ha.
Founder Office: Lame.
Suresh: deep blue.
Founder Office: Geoffre?
Founder Office: karate.
Chathura Praboda: Okay, fam.
Suresh: dish.
Chathura Praboda: study.
Suresh: Blues. They fail.
Founder Office: Guy faire?
Suresh: Dash rest…
Founder Office: Okay? i, okay?
Founder Office: mobile decor kameti.
Suresh: When Geth fell.
Founder Office: Jim Geffet.
Suresh: Does hand… what am I gonna handicana?
Founder Office: That's, that's handy.
Suresh: Just sending, right? Yeah. VIN?
Founder Office: Give it, thus.
Founder Office: Handy, okay? Vem Gefer das Handy.
Suresh: Das handicke failure.
Founder Office: Yeah, das Hande Feldmann.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Das Auto G Ferrnie.
Founder Office: Miya.
Suresh: Do you think?
Founder Office: kuleva.
Founder Office: E completed.
Founder Office: gehert mea.
Founder Office: Okie digger.
Founder Office: seh.
Founder Office: karaanne.
Suresh: Yeah.
Founder Office: definite article leka.
Founder Office: indefinite article recorded.
Founder Office: me nunich.
Founder Office: Yetu kote.
Founder Office: Do. Helix.
Founder Office: Der Mutter.
Suresh: to it.
Founder Office: Do hirifs dea mute.
Suresh: Do hilt.
Chathura Praboda: Who has their father.
Chathura Praboda: Enjoy.
Founder Office: I can name fanton in there, yeah? To his damn farther.
Founder Office: hai.
Founder Office: Ish, huh?
Suresh: Right.
Founder Office: Ich helfer einm Freund.
Founder Office: Webstick.
Founder Office: Yeah?
Founder Office: in jana.
Founder Office: There's a lot.
Founder Office: Webs.
Founder Office: Pullua.
Founder Office: Okay? discuss kar mo.
Founder Office: She's got 38 in.
Suresh: Yeah, bless you in.
Suresh: Russ, fuck.
Founder Office: mukhadagate tena.
Suresh: LinkedIn.
Founder Office: Dame grows harder. Via gratulieren, via gratulieren. Dame grows harder, yeah?
Founder Office: namaha.
Founder Office: Hmm…
Suresh: Secret.
Founder Office: Di zigaratil shade.
Founder Office: Shadan.
Founder Office: Okay, then…
Suresh: I'm guessing that can people.
Founder Office: Sha… Tektetter.
Suresh: Decent health, health.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Founder Office: Die Gesund height perkum daputrega.
Suresh: Mmm, so you got it charted? Yeah.
Founder Office: there.
Suresh: Yes, I'll.
Founder Office: Right, yeah. These cigarettes shardet der Gesundheit.
Founder Office: Duncan tamai webbeki ka, daikan webbeka, kapi kalina tiga nagata, do dungst little.
Founder Office: Do dang.
Suresh: Dude, yeah.
Founder Office: karan.
Suresh: Bin.
Founder Office: Then, yeah? Do dancest, then Ilton.
Founder Office: Do dunks, then return. Do dunks, then return.
Founder Office: air facilit.
Founder Office: To forgive, kayne kasama, yeah? For cyan to forgive.
Suresh: For a second.
Founder Office: Er, for sight.
Founder Office: Freundin.in.
Suresh: I in a friend.
Founder Office: Einer finding, yeah? A for site, einer Finding.
Founder Office: fur.
Suresh: Good.
Founder Office: Right.
Suresh: Fight.
Founder Office: ini.
Founder Office: air… The trout, covered, which one?
Founder Office: Dame Fanta.
Founder Office: trust karna, Di kinder.
Suresh: vision.
Founder Office: ka.
Suresh: To demonstrate.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Suresh: Sort of down the dead.
Founder Office: der Mutter soul.
Founder Office: Die kinder heran der Muta sol lamai amata sana.
Founder Office: glauban.
Founder Office: Freund.
Suresh: I know, friend.
Founder Office: infinity feat.
Suresh: Definitely.
Founder Office: Definitely.
Founder Office: You can't have a big.
Suresh: They are film, they felt…
Founder Office: Loynton que la de latino. Lighten Thank you for coming soon.
Suresh: The den…
Founder Office: Enlighten.
Founder Office: meinne.
Suresh: I'm a Canadian.
Founder Office: Okay? Okay?
Founder Office: Derfilm, gefert, der Leiten nicht.
Founder Office: Municipal tenure.
Founder Office: Schmidt.
Suresh: Schmidst. Schmidt.
Suresh: I changed.
Founder Office: Das ice Schmidt.
Founder Office: Lehschm nicht.
Suresh: Mitch.
Founder Office: ice cream maker.
Founder Office: 100.
Suresh: I dare mention?
Founder Office: Yeah, mint, mint villagan, that's
Founder Office: Yeah, it's gotta be a mansioned.
Founder Office: kannya.
Founder Office: Ilang keto.
Founder Office: Di yaka, yaka kyanne jahat thicker. Di yaka, ilangeta verb beka mitane passan kian mechwin na suout, passan.
Suresh: Limkin.
Founder Office: past methodi.
Founder Office: Jane Quint nicht.
Founder Office: pin in a hand gym.
Founder Office: nicht. Nichtek negative sentence. Ramenata jacket tek galapin akirana kohunaki, meh, no.
Suresh: Nish, takea nethukin.
Founder Office: di yake past DM kint. Sorry, sentenciv kara pe niche.
Founder Office: Elaborate?
Founder Office: Dian sala.
Suresh: Schmier. Schmicht.
Suresh: Schmidt.
Suresh: Deshaischmicht.
Founder Office: Yeah, there's an art.
Founder Office: Guestana.
Suresh: Dane… Dane Giston.
Founder Office: 10 guests turn, okay?
Founder Office: Okay? Keela.
Founder Office: Yeah, there's anat. Schmicht den Gaston, nicht.
Suresh: technished.
Chathura Praboda: niche.
Founder Office: Okay. Helfan opa.
Suresh: Dame OPA.
Founder Office: dem opa, okay?
Founder Office: Google Classroom meke ka, ke, Yeah.
Founder Office: Yeah, podak baranda mitane.
Founder Office: nih.
Suresh: Mmm, they coughed.
Suresh: Damar, neither…
Founder Office: Yeah, then you decline.
Suresh: cafe.
Suresh: Organic.
Suresh: Alright, Dahun flaut.
Founder Office: fault.
Founder Office: dame.
Founder Office: Infinity fabric many fallen.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Hmm.
Founder Office: Der hunt fault, Dharma kian lady, d-lady, yeah? As in, sorry, di dharm lady.
Suresh: Home of the community.
Founder Office: Der Hund?
Founder Office: Pault. They're down.
Founder Office: Der honk der Dame.
Founder Office: thin bar as well.
Founder Office: There, cough, Tot dea manwei. Yeah.
Suresh: M.
Founder Office: cough?
Founder Office: To demon.
Founder Office: beka.
Suresh: Sue Horan. V Horan?
Suresh: Larry.
Founder Office: Good in.
Suresh: Layering… D-layerin.
Founder Office: kada.
Suresh: Yeah.
Founder Office: Rami.
Suresh: Yeah, yeah.
Founder Office: Yeah, via la… via…
Founder Office: Okay, we are here and there leurin. So, ka.
Founder Office: me, no.
Founder Office: had agar. Okay?
Founder Office: bala.
Founder Office: Okay, how can I finish this?
Suresh: I didn't know that.
Chathura Praboda: Oh, free to say that.
Founder Office: It's longer. Okay, I'll feed us in.